we spent
three years in ivedan national park in
northeastern argentina
the cappuccino cedars are distributed
throughout south america
and they don't appear to have any clear
geographic barriers that prevent them
from exchanging genes
these various cappuccino species are
genetically very similar
they breed in the same habitat and they
eat the same food
and yet the males of these various
species differ in plumage coloration and
song
terbek and her team focused on two types
of cappuccinos
the tawny bellied seed eater and the
ibera sea eater which was undiscovered
until 2001. these two species
along with eight others split from a
single common ancestor
within the last million years this
relatively
recent rapid expansion occurred even as
they shared practically the same
neighborhood
normally for speciation to occur
organisms have to be confined to
different geographic regions
in order to accumulate genetic
differences and we've seen this process
occur in other radiations such as
darwin's finches where
from a single common ancestor they've
formed many different species that are
confined to different islands in the
galapagos
capuchino sea eaters in general and the
iwasivita and tanibelli cedar are
confined to continental south america
and they lack any obvious spatial or
temporal barriers to reproduction
it's unclear what kind of barriers
maintain these two species
in the same geographic area and keep
them distinct from one another
we searched for nest of the ebitda
seeder and the tawny bellied seed eater
we marked individual birds with unique
combination of color bands
and we collected blood samples from
adults and nestlings these two species
we presented territorial males of the
ebedasider and the tawny bellied seeder
with painted mounts and song recordings
that mimicked their own species song and
plumage
as well as that of the other cappuccino
species and recorded their aggressive
responses
both cappuccino species responded most
aggressively to
the song and plumage of their own
species and less aggressively
when the song or plumage belonged to the
other species which suggests that both
of these traits
are jointly used in order to distinguish
one another in territorial interactions
and avoid interbreeding we
sequence the dna of the two species in
order to determine how they differ
on a genetic level as well as analyze
patterns of meat choice in order to
assess whether these two cappuccinos
ever interbreed in the wild
and to our surprise we found that even
though these species breed side by side
and they share the same resources in
yubata national park
the iburasi duder and the tawny belly
cedar are only ever
mated with members of their own species
since the two cappuccino species are so
genetically similar
terbeck's team essentially was searching
for needles in a haystack
the iberassi duder and the tawny belly
cedar are almost
identical on a genetic level and they
can only be distinguished by three tiny
regions of their genome that only
contain 12 genes
three of these genes are known to be
involved in plumage coloration in other
bird species
and have likely contributed to the
diverse plumage patterns that we observe
in this group
ebitda seeded are likely formed as a
result of past hybridization between
cappuccino lineages
and the subsequent reshuffling of
genetic variation
into novel combinations that encode
differences in plumage patterning and
potentially male song differences in
song and plumage alone may be sufficient
to maintain species boundaries
extremely early in divergence
[Music]
work remains to determine if
cappuccino's songs diverge
genetically or if their differences are
entirely learned
it's also unknown whether the distinct
cappuccino genes associated with plumage
are actively expressed for now the
bera and tawny bellied seed eaters will
likely continue mating within their own
species
despite sharing the same turf and almost
all the same genes
as the saying goes birds of a feather
flock together
[Music]